on his way to work youch in Yannick
stops by to check on the Syrian refugee
families in the neighborhood and asked
them how they're doing and if they need
anything they call him yo chin ABI
brother yaojin is Turkish but in his
home town Izmir he's often himself taken
for a refugee specifically he's an F ro
Turk a descendant of African slaves
brought here in the mid 19th century by
the Ottoman Empire on the streets and
even in his own leather workshop he's
been called black in a derogatory manner
or utter Turkish for Arab these remarks
even come from my own acquaintances
although their mentis jokes a year might
go by without any remarks like that at
all and then I might hear them 10 times
in one week but Turks of African origin
like Yelchin yannick are growing more
confident once a year they celebrate a
festival in Izmir with people coming all
the way from the Americas and Africa his
mears mayor also came to underscore his
liberal image but many passers-by are
still surprised that afro Turks exist
really these people here I wasn't aware
of them
very few of the Afro Turks themselves
know their roots forced assimilation has
consigned their history and culture to
oblivion now their descendants want to
change that some years ago they founded
an association for the purpose we have
been able to say who we are exactly of
course where Turks were born here but
there's more to it something was always
missing in a disadvantaged suburb of
Izmir the yannick family sits down to
breakfast like most afro Turks they're
of modest means they have little time to
delve into their past the out scene
believes his ancestors came from
Tanzania but that's about all he knows
if you do want to research it hardly any
documents from that time can be found
gives you your genes children haven't
learned anything about the history of
the African slaves in school either
it's not even mentioned but they've had
their experiences with day to day racism
miserable I really don't like to be in
crowds feel uncomfortable and frightened
there was a kid it was worse we tried to
hide under a chair come on get out the
annual afro Turk Festival concludes with
a big picnic the yonex try to get
together with other efforts more often
these days
the food here is Turkish the music too
but recently grass skirts and brightly
colored shirts have become popular
nobody here can afford an actual trip to
Africa so they're happy to see more and
more Africans visiting Turkey whenever
we meet people from Nigeria Sudan here
in Turkey we invite them over and up
them tell us all about their home
countries and cultures of course we'd
like to travel to Africa ourselves maybe
someday this dream will come true but
youch in yannick wants to bring about
change here in Turkey in 2018 he ran for
Parliament as a candidate for a
left-wing party but he didn't collect
enough votes to become the first afro
Turkish representative in the Grand
National Assembly
we're already more visible in many areas
of society now it's time for us to go
into politics time for a black president
or Minister or just a black village
elder Jochen Yannick thinks the time is
ripe some 160 years after slavery was
abolished afro Turks are demanding their
place in Turkish society